I'm Natasha wavelet I'm in Scotland at
the Edinburgh Fringe Festival I'm gonna
find out what's going on you're not
wearing any Fringe so do you feel
embarrassed no because there's no about
bringing food think I've seen the best
fringe so far they're really taking the
French to another level
clearly you guys got the memo all right
we've got great fringe
we've got great friends I don't need
friends
I got ass so what does my fringe say
about me yeah yeah anything I thought it
was about like garments and maybe that's
not what it no absolutely not no it was
totally
our people talking about the fringe TV
show created by JJ Abrams that was on
Fox for five seasons
no what is okay good joke
okay clearly your favorite TV show oh
yeah I'm never out of it so tell me
who's your favorite from bringe no still
wrong place you've come to the wrong
place no you know I'm guessing you don't
want this you've done there again it's
the same name but it's actually a
different thing I literally think this
has nothing to do with what's going on
if you weren't talking enough about
fringe benefit you know me like tuition
assistance right adoption assistance
right gym memberships Pilates at 4 p.m.
you guys get me I like to be treated to
huge quantities of haggis and blood
pudding while I'm here and that is
something an employer will provide for
you I was gonna say health you would
hope that there would just be plenty of
washrooms at your employer's you'd think
not in Scotland Wow everyone just pees
everywhere around ok you heard it here
first
fringe everyone's pissed in everyone
clearly you mean fringe like no the
weirdos some weirdos I don't know that
many weirdos say I'll go first
okay I like to lick candy and not eat it
okay I like to eat cereal dry okay I can
say the alphabet backwards in like three
seconds let's do it
Zed y xw v TS r QP o n m lk j IH d f e d
c ba okay get that woman to show every
now and then I like to do a poo with the
door open okay question follow which
door as many as possible are you a
performer at the Fringe because that
feels like is that you're weird or show
that you'd be a pretty shitty show I
don't like to eat bugs you like I like
to eat bugs I steal from the government
yeah in many ways you are the perfect
person in the fridge Wow I guess in the
end that fringe was about me all along
well thank you guys so much thank
goodness okay I have found an actual
fringe performer David Karl who's gonna
tell me finally okay what is the fringe
about yeah it's the largest arts
festival in the world there's over 3,000
shows yeah
you've got comedy you've got dance but
ballet so you're telling me the fringes
of 27 Day Festival where there were
3,000 shows yeah okay can you just take
okay I got a lot of okay yeah all right
you